walk into any waffle house and you'll be
greeted by the familiar sounds of
breakfast bacon sizzling coffee brewing
hash browns crunching and the piercing
ding of a waffle iron ready for more
batter but listen closely and you'll
hear a truly unique sound
what's that there are raisins in my
toast who writes a song about toast
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen meet shelby i'm
shelby white and i'm the president of
waffle records
waffle what
waffle records is the in-house record
label of waffle house waffle records of
course waffle records was created as a
way to add waffle content to the jukebox
we originally created the songs in 1984.
chairman said you know what we need a
record label
[Music]
there are currently 47 waffle house
songs on the jukebox
some of our songs on the jukebox are
especially at the waffle house
grill operator
i saw elvis at the waffle house
building a record label all about
breakfast foods is no small feat so
shelby and the team at waffle house turn
to music producers like jason phelps
hi i'm jason phelps i write and produce
music for waffle records to make a song
for waffle house it starts with an idea
and that idea generally is the title
or what the song's gonna be about
sometimes the idea is more serious like
veterans returning home but sometimes
it's more silly like having raisins in
your toast this last song that we did
called only at the waffle house was very
much about crazy things that can happen
at the waffle house
[Music]
people give birth at the waffle house
somebody one time rode a horse to the
waffle house there are lots of things
that happen so the songs almost end up
sort of writing themselves
once you have all this good content
we do take it very seriously in terms of
our craft but music is fun and the
waffle house is fun
who doesn't like that marriage
[Music]